the hero's journey
is one of the most important archetypes
to understand
the hero's journey is a call
to the unknown it's an invitation to
play
in new possibilities
and this is typically seen through
somebody that
maybe feeling a little bit depressed
a little bit anxious a little bit angry
they want to feel happiness joy peace
somebody in a nine to five feeling like
they're in the rat race
and they want to explore what exists
in entrepreneurship or in art or in
spirituality
this is what happens when people are
called to adventure and new geographies
around the planet
meeting new cultures around the planet
this is what happens when people feel
like they want to move
out of their small hometown and move
into one of the big cities
and you might ask yourself what
is learned in the unknown what
is the treasure that is learned in the
unknown
and then why is it so important for the
individual to venture
into the unknown to gain this treasure
to transform themselves
and then to come back and integrate that
into their communities into the world
when you look at people like
not only carl jung and joseph campbell
and the study of archetypes and the
study of
people's psychology and also you have
many of the planetary spiritual
traditions that have been
honed in on refining these types of
visualizations for their individuals
that go
out an adventure into the unknown become
transformed learn the treasure
and then come back and integrate it into
community and world
when you see that spirituality and
science come together in this way when
you see that this
psychological archetype has been so well
documented even scientifically
it's important to take it seriously
because there's something so deep inside
of you
that wants to explore what is unknown
there's the exact counter force inside
of you
where you have on one end this stasis
the stagnation
and on this other side you have this
entropic
force you have this force towards chaos
this force towards a disorder this force
towards exploration of what is a
potential higher possibility
and you notice it so subtly in your
everyday life
when you notice that you had some
thought
that arose that was angry and frustrated
and you wonder
well what can i read or what can i learn
or how can i understand myself
and consciousness better for me to feel
happiness
and peace and more at ease or
again you may feel like you're at work
and you may feel like you've been at
work for
years and you got a degree at a
university and that you've been
serving the man you've been serving the
economy you've been
feeling like a cog in a machine
and you feel like why do i feel
something inside of me that doesn't
necessarily feel whole
and so you may be called to adventure
into a new culture a new geography
a new field that may be entrepreneurial
it may be artistic it may be creative it
may be scientific it may be engineering
it may be spiritual
it may be with computers and artificial
intelligence it might be with
pressing technologies it might be turned
deeply inward investigating
the heart and investigating
consciousness it might be investigating
what is the nature of
reality
what is infinity and you might be
called to these deeper investigations
you might feel like why am i in my
hometown
i've been in my hometown for 18 years
i've been in my hometown for 30 years
why have i not left the country before
why have i never met people
that are from different countries why
don't i have
intimate relationships with friends of
different backgrounds
from around the world and what would
that do
to my fear what would that do
to my
what the media and propaganda has been
conditioning
me through my subconscious to fear the
other
what would happen what would change
if i exposed myself to these unknowns
what would happen if i could shake the
hand or
hug somebody that i had previously
subconsciously feared
whether they be on the opposite side of
the political spectrum
or whether they be from a culture around
the world that's been demonized
and these are the ways to view the
journey into the unknown the call to
adventure
because every single time that you take
this call to adventure that you become
more and more subtle and more and more
sensitive with detecting
when this call to adventure arises
the more and more you'll feel meaning
you'll feel purpose you'll feel
fulfillment you'll feel excitement
you'll feel
aliveness
and the reason why people like myself
can speak about this so intimately
aiming to share it with you and land it
in your heart so you also gain the
subtlety
and the excitement around these calls to
adventure is because i've been there and
i've done that
many different times throughout my life
i had the example when i was 17
in sioux falls south dakota and wanting
to leave to go to minneapolis
minnesota a bigger city with more
cultures more diversity
more new perspectives points of views to
be able to synthesize and integrate into
a more
holistic picture
and the same thing happened again with
another call to adventure when i was 19
and i had all these entrepreneurs coming
from silicon valley
to the entrepreneurship club and they
were speaking
and they were exciting me about
executing my ideas
and so i got pumped and i took the call
to adventure to drop out of college and
move to silicon valley
and to learn through entrepreneurship
through trial and error through science
through art through spirituality to come
to
these understandings over a period of a
decade
and i became more and more subtle and
sensitive
to detect when these beautiful openings
and possibilities came
and the same thing's true for you
i love you dearly
that's why i'm sharing this message i'm
taking the time to share this message
with you
because i know that if even the tiniest
opening arises for you from this message
for you to become more aware of what's
happening in your
life for you to seize the moment
seize the new possibility go on that
call to adventure
into the unknown and transform yourself
and gain this beautiful treasure and
knowledge and be able to
share that with the community in the
world that you
will never be the same and you will feel
so incredibly indescribable
transformed afterward and you will even
become
more and more of a junkie for new
possibilities
for more awakened states for more
exploring how to maximize not only your
own individual potential
but the collective's potential
you have everything that you need inside
of you
right now
everything that you need is already
inside of you
it's just up to you right now can you
muster up the courage
to see where in your life are you being
shown
these new possibilities in this call to
adventure
and can you seize the moment and seize
the opportunity
and go and explore the unknown and learn
so much cooler than stasis and
stagnation
and just chilling for hours and watching
shows or scrolling pointlessly through
social media
or going to the same local bars and
clubs
and sporting events and talking to the
same people that are also in a place of
stasis or stagnation
listening to your family that wants you
to stay put
and then all of a sudden you get this
piece of content like this
and this piece of content is like maybe
i should
grow more maybe i should burst
from what feels like it's holding me
back with all of my
local peers and my in my family
and my environment
and all the people that i existingly
follow on social accounts
and maybe i should burst out of that
maybe there's
new possibilities that will
transform me so profoundly that i will
become so awakened individually to my
full potential and be able to bring
such incredible meaning and prosperity
to the world as well
from the smallest impacts to the
grandest ones
and how important that is
so there are two primary
driving forces there's love and there's
fear
and when you look at it like this carrot
and stick
it can really sort of help land in your
heart
how important it is to take these new
possibilities seriously
so on one side you have this love
and you have this carrot and it is what
you will uncover
by going into the unknown it is what you
will uncover by exploring these higher
possibilities
this treasure that you will obtain this
transmutation that you will undergo
and what you will be able to bring to
your family the community in the world
and then on this other side you have
fear
and you have the stick and on that side
you have things like tony robbins and
unleash the power within has a really
incredible meditation that i've gone
under several times attending as well as
as crew
at his events and you'll have the whole
audience 10
000 plus people undergo a process
of closing their eyes and you can do
this exercise
right now with me and visualize
what it would be like
if you had the deepest most
profound regret and
sorrow and hatred and anger and
suffering for yourself because you did
not
pursue what were these highest
possibilities
tune into the feeling that comes in your
heart
when you would look back at your life on
your deathbed and regret
you not pursuing these higher
possibilities
imagine it
feel into that regret the remorse the
anger the frustration
the stasis and stagnation in your teens
20s 30s 40s 50s 60s every time one of
these opportunities was presented to you
that you did not seize it you did not
explore it because you were fearful of
the unknown
and now visualize yourself absolutely
shattering that possibility absolutely
breaking
out of that limitation and unleashing
yourself at your
absolute individual highest
and feel that now in your heart feel the
exact
opposite to the total worst outcome
and now you're feeling the absolute
highest
outcome and so now hold that in your
heart
hold that so dearly in your heart
and perpetually focus your life around
what does it look like for my unique
individual
to experience the absolute highest
possibility
hold that in your heart some more what
does it look like for you
what does it look like what will you
awaken to
about yourself how will you transform
yourself
how will you transform your family the
community the world
what kind of unique gift will you bring
to society
how will you uniquely express yourself
out of the stasis and stagnation and
towards the unknown towards the treasure
towards the transmutation
and project that out 5 years 10 years 15
years 20 years do some future
authoring with yourself around why you
should take
all of these opportunities to explore
the
unknown
and now you see that vision for yourself
you see it more and more clearly in this
north star
position you see it more and more
clearly in your highest desire you see
it more and more clearly as your unique
blueprint is calling you to explore
these higher possibilities and you feel
that in your heart and you
see that as your north star and now that
becomes
your more natural state that becomes
your more
normal perpetual state is coming
from the place of being excited to
explore higher possibilities
rather than coming from a place of being
so
worried and concerned and stagnant and
stasis
and fearful of the unknown
beautiful so now that we have this
background
which is so important to the hero's
journey you have to remember that this
isn't just me
these are tens of thousands of people
over the span of not only a hundred
years in psychology but in thousands of
years in spiritual traditions
that have been studied to understand
this archetype
and that's why we're communicating it to
you
so that you can also unleash yourself
fully maximizing your own potential in
the world's potential
the world seeks your gifts the world is
pumped about your gifts
your family the community are pumped
about you actualizing your fullest
potential
and your life will feel so much more
truly
well lived by going on these calls to
adventure
so what could you do
even at the most extreme what could you
do
right after watching this video
where if you were to die
in the foreseeable future
that within the day within the week
within the month within the year
you will feel like you have lived a full
life
what could you do in the day the week
the month the year and this future
authoring process
that if you were to die that you would
feel
so alive that you had accomplished
so much that you had transformed
yourself so much that you brought
yourself and your family and the
community and the world so much value
in the shortest amount of time so how
can you transform yourself that way
and tap into that love for exploration
tap into that love for the unknown
tap into the love for getting through
these biggest challenges for the
learning experience of going through the
assistance of mentors and going through
the process of being revealed these new
ways of
seeing
and being able to return transformed
to further serve and shepherd
steward
one of the most important things to
remember about what happens
in the call to adventure and especially
hitting these thresholds
is that you're gonna undergo a process
of having a test of faith
these are so continuous
throughout your life
because even though right now you may
feel so transformed
what's gonna happen is right after this
video
you're gonna get a test of faith
and you're gonna get another test of
faith tomorrow and it's gonna
test you and it's gonna be like well
sure you watched that video but
all of this stuff around stasis and
stagnation
and comfort and safety and validation
and
those are more important
and that's going to be your test of
faith right after this video
can you undergo a process of breaking
free
from those scripts unfreezing
more of your will and sovereignty and
choice and power and courage
and honor and duty
and so undergo a very reflective process
here
you're gonna finish watching the video
you're gonna have this opportunity
to kind of journal around your future
authoring about what was transformed in
your heart space about
your future and then to look at that
when you wake up in the morning because
there's gonna be another test of faith
and so remember to keep the
idea of the test of faith very
clear in your awareness
in your concepts because you're gonna
more and more come up to these tests of
faith that happen
and that you're gonna have to see
through them very quickly because
otherwise they will revert you back to
where you were
and so you're you have faith you have
courage
it's your honor and your duty to pursue
into the unknown
one of the other core components is
the mentor
if you don't already have a mentor
ask yourself why you don't
and it's good to have a mentor
that is in the media space that
you don't necessarily know personally
intimately in person like for example
jordan peterson has been a big mentor
to many especially young men that are
going on such heroes journeys
and this is good if you don't have a
mentor in the digital space like that
then find one because that's
a critical step in this process
because they will also be helping guide
you with
better and better ways to navigate
through opening yourself up to higher
possibilities
and then i would also say get a mentor
that helps you in person as well
so you not only have access to this
incredible online catalog
of content of these greatest mentors but
you also have
the test that's right here can
you find a local mentor
in person for you to
meet with and for you to vulnerably and
honestly ask for help
similarly to 10 years ago for me there
was a process of constantly reaching out
even five years ago still constantly
reaching out
aiming to get more and more mentorship
diverse
mentorship totally open and vulnerable
about that process
and every single time that i would get
that mentorship my life would so
profoundly be augmented
and so i highly suggest tuning into
what can it be that somebody that has
been there done
that what wisdom can they pass along
to me to you in this case that
can so much help you on this process on
this journey
so that little bit of wisdom from
somebody that has been there and done
that
can accelerate your journey so that you
don't fall into the same mistakes the
same
crevices the same holes
but instead you see through them faster
and you avoid them
because you've learned from those
mentors
so in a sense you're looking for signal
you're looking for signal
where is the unknown what treasure is
there what transformation is there for
me
what is the signal in how to transcend
through these tests of faith in these
challenges these obstacles
if you increase your desire more and
more the
obstacles will melt more and more
the signal is also there with your
mentors
and so all of this will lead you to
this incredible revelation this
incredible
transformation this incredible abyss
and rebirth it's a roller coaster
of life there's going to be many ups
there's going to be many downs
and through those ups and downs do you
know how to see through them
quickly and efficiently
your greatest traumas are your greatest
treasures
do you know how to transmute transform
those greatest traumas
very quickly into these greatest
treasures these greatest wisdoms these
greatest insights that you can then pass
along to other people
and so this is what is meant by the
process of rebirthing
having a revelation having a
transformation a transmutation that is
so
unbelievably profound so
for you by going out to these bigger
cities in the metros
by you pursuing entrepreneurship art
science engineering spirituality
by you exposing yourself to these
new possibilities what is going to
happen is with a period within a period
of a couple days you'll start feeling it
more and more
especially as you've left the existing
sta
stasis and stagnant waters and within
those weeks
and months you're gonna feel so
many of these ups and downs along the
way
but you see through them you see how
they're serving you you see how it's all
part of that hero's journey of
transformation
and then these bigger rebirths and
revelations happen
and then you're no longer the same
that's when you're truly no longer the
same you've went through such a radical
transformation evolution growth
awakening in your consciousness that
you've been exposed
to these new possibilities that you can
never
look at that same person before you
started the hero's journey
the same way that you'll feel completely
different from that person
before the hero's journey who was that
guy who was that girl before the hero's
journey
that wasn't me look at who i am now
after this revelation after this
transformation
and that's the feeling that's the
feeling of growth
that's the feeling of your honor and
duty
to evolve yourself
to gain the wisdom to gain through the
challenges through the obstacles getting
the mentors getting the help along the
way
through those ups and downs transforming
yourself
through going into the unknown on these
adventures
over and over again and gaining all of
that insight and then coming back
to society to your family to your
community
to the world at large and delivering
them
the treasures the transformations that
you've went through
and you can make that into art you can
write about it
in journals you can make videos about it
you can write poetry about it you can
make beautiful
art you can you can go through a process
of sharing what you've done
through an entrepreneurial journey all
of a sudden you have a product or
service that's available
that one person uses 10 people use 100
people use
you've went through a process of
discovering something profound in the
sciences
you've went through a process of turning
inward and recognizing more and more
how to be peaceful and how to be happy
and joyful and less angry and depressed
and anxious and then you can share that
with other people
everything you uncover in the hero's
journey you get to share with other
people it's so
beautiful
you go and you uncover all of this gold
that was latent within your blueprint
the whole time that you awakened
by doing things like summoning up the
courage to go on this adventure
and then you have this gold that you get
to share with people
because you left the stasis you left the
stagnation
and look at these great stories that you
now have look at this great wisdom that
you now have
look at these great projects that you
have under your belt look at these great
awakenings
that you now have
this is why the hero's journey is one of
the most
important archetypes
period
i love you so much
take this this hero's journey archetype
and figure out where it applies
in your life where you can venture into
the unknown
for an adventure that then
profoundly transforms you
and then you get to share that wisdom
from that transformation
and you get to live a life
that feels so much more empowering so
much more fulfilling
so much more alive and in love
with your unique individuation
in this reality
infinite love for you thank you for
tuning in
i would love to hear where you're at in
your own hero's journeys
where you've been what obstacles you've
gotten through
what you've learned how you've been
transformed what gifts you've come back
and shared with the world
or if you haven't yet left into the
unknown how i can serve you
how i can shepherd you so let me know in
the comments
if the video brought you value give it a
like helps the algorithm
get it to more people subscribe to the
channel if you haven't yet
share the video with other people that
you feel like
the hero's journey would profoundly land
in their hearts
and create that big transformative
change
let's do this baby all
individuals have these little
transformations
within them that can create so
big of butterfly effects on themselves
fully actualizing and on their
communities in the world
fully actualizing just by moving from a
place of stasis to a place of growth
from a place of fear to a place of love
for exploration and new possibilities
so let's popularize it let's do it
thank you again
infinite love
you